b s take one C Mark can you just fire me
already Google Play I would never fire
you in fact all foolishness aside this
represents
foolishness for continuity I won't do
that
R I'm a superhero I'm not tech support
but you are supported by Tech there's a
rumor that your ding Dong's just a dish
Network satellite who said that if I'm
being real that was that was right off
the
Doom play who said that Alfred who said
that Alfred well no I said it to Alfred
wouldn't it be great if Cyborg's
ding-dong with three or four D batteries
he said very good sir and he said very
good
sir I
[Music]
don't or if your dick was a 12vt it oh
yeah and when the smoke detector's out
we break off a piece of your dick
everything's fine is this why you
brought me here man I'm so just imagine
which different machines my dick could
be you like that no I cannot help you
get a CD onto your iPhone I'm not your
grandson okay how about an album that's
in my Dropbox get it on my iPhone as a
playable album I can only play it in the
Dropbox app and I'm going back in I'm
driving and I'm going in and selecting a
new song every every 3 minutes that's
not safe help you can finally do
something
look sorry let's take a peek at the
script I
don't but then when my girlfriend died
by the hand of twoof face cuz he
confused me with a
riddle r one sorry for your loss
actually it was Joker Joker confused me
with the riddle let me do it
again and let's say when she died you
felt kind of weird about looking at
pictures of her titties yeah but now
enough time has passed and you'd really
like to see those titties again and
you've tried hear me out you tried to
make do with their autopsy
photos
what you sure you want to go with that
choice
oh
yeah also I'm starting to
cry you want me to help you find your
dead girlfriend's
photos so that you can
masturbate I'll pay you in some of the
above the waist
ones
no that's a horrible deal for me whether
I was a creep or not
yeah I'm quitting I'm not your jiny
nephew here to teach you about Tik Tok
I'm a human being are you sure cuz you
look like somebody got covered in Honey
and rolled through a Radio Shack don't
stand still at your yard sale pieces
you'll fly for 15
cents why did that feel too
[Laughter]
mean you can't command Q the Justice
League I command F you oh command f you
you want to find
something command I call you out that my
Rift doesn't
work we did it you're having a hard time
understanding me let me put this in ways
you can understand I speak
[Music]
AOL
goodbye
all
[Music]